[Applause]
on symbolic execution using symbolic
all right hello everybody I'm John
Pietro and today I will be talking about
relational symbolic execution for
differential privacy some of you in the
audience might have already heard a few
things about this topic but I apologize
if it's gonna be a bit boring anyway so
I'm a programming language person and in
particular I come from the formal
verification community and during this
week there were already two talks about
formal verification and in particular
the main idea of their work was that
they would build an engine based on some
kind of type system or logics that whose
main goal was basically to take an input
a piece of code and a specification for
instance the specification of
differential privacy and then output yes
if the program was indeed differentially
private plus some evidence of this of
this fact that we call proof or forma
proof and in the case where the program
wasn't differentially private then the
program would not say yes or would say I
don't know and I'm looking at this kind
of problem from a different perspective
in the sense that I'm looking at what
happens when the proof fails and in
particular I'm thinking about an engine
that describing you an engine that takes
an input a source code and a
specification differential privacy and
outputs basically know when the program
is not differentially private plus some
evidence of this fact some information
and this information some this kind of
feedback could out the developer to fix
his code or to understand why why the
form of proof fails if the developer has
some background about formal methods
what counts as kind of feedback is a
counter example for instance a counter
example to absolute on differential
privacy for a program see look ideally
looked like as a pair of databases
the 1 and the 2 that are adjacent and an
event a description an event such that
the output distribution on the Courant
of the program when we fill it with
these two databases assign mass to this
event that basically violate the privacy
bound that we want to respect and there
have been already works on how to you
know the kind of automatize this kind of
search but some of them were kind of
basic base Thanh statistical approach
like approximating the output
distribution of the of the of the
program on schranz and trying to see
approximately where the bound was
violated what I'm trying to look at is
to use a different approach which is
called symbolic execution which is a
standard technique in program analysis
that it has been studied seen from the
since from the 70s but exactly I want to
use this approach to look for bugs and
counter example for differential privacy
now since I'm aware some people here
might not be familiar with the concept
of symbolic execution or try to give a
crash course on symbolic execution and a
few in a few slides and the idea is that
we can take this piece of code as a very
simple example and this piece of code
just takes in input some integer X and
the branches on the predicate even X and
if even ax is true then it assigns to
the variable in output X square
otherwise it outputs x squared minus 1
okay and this is the piece of code while
the specification there are many ways to
describe what a specification is and one
way to do that is to provide two
predicates one is the what we call
usually precondition and it's a it's
some kind of predicate on the on the
data the end of the of the program and
it's some assumption that
can assume while we analyze the the
program and then the other part of the
specification it's called pass condition
and in this case says out greater than
zero and it's something that we want to
have no matter what whenever we executed
the program starting from a state where
the variable X is greater than zero or
better said when the precondition is
true and let's see how we can so this
this precondition this try pole is not
valid obviously in the sense that there
are values of X which satisfied the
precondition but that lead to a final
state where the first condition is not
true but the question is how we can do
this how we can understand this using
symbolic execution and is that exactly
how the name says we execute
symbolically the code and now the
executing symbolically the code means
that now the variable X is doesn't have
a concrete value but it has a symbolic
value and this means that it denotes a
set of possible concrete values and this
set of concrete integers gets refined
during the XA doing the symbolic
execution through the creation of new
constraint that refine the variable X
but now the first execution of the of
our simple program is a branch
instruction but we don't have a concrete
value for X so we have to really follow
both branches and in one case we follow
the true branch and we assume in that
true branch that X is indeed even and
then we create a new symbolic relation
between out and end X which says that
out is equal to X square but we don't
have concrete values for them they are
just symbols and the other branch in the
other branch we do the same and we
create though a different relation
between the symbols X and and out now
the idea is that we can in this way
create
what we call in in the field of path
conditions pc1 & pc2 that they note a
set of possible trucks sorry a set of
possible traces of the program and then
the idea is that that the past condition
is true if all the path condition
implies logically the path condition and
this is obviously not the case because
the past condition PC Chu does not imply
the post condition and this check can be
done by a standard off-the-shelf SMT
solver or constraint solver and that
when finds out that the implication is
not valid
gives us back counter example in
particular a set of values that satisfy
the the past condition sorry the path
condition pc2 but that lead to a state
where the past condition is not true
okay this is a very short crash course
on what symbolic execution is and the
idea is that we want to apply this
concept to differential privacy but
differential privacy as we all know is a
relational property in the sense that we
are always talking about two runs of the
same program on two inputs that are
related and we want to prove some post
condition which talks again about
outputs that are related so the idea I'm
gonna now abstract away from details is
that we are going to consider two
symbolic symbolic executions paired up
and this great triangles mean basically
that the program could have loop so it
could be you know infinite in theory but
we always pick a number of maximum
iterations to stop the execution and the
idea now is that we don't follow only
one track but we basically start from
relating states and following and then
we follow paths that are related
okay and during this so during this
relational symbolic execution we don't
only gather constraint relative to one
path for instance the one on on the on
the left but the constraints are going
to be relational as well so they are
gonna relate related States and so this
is what we would like basically to use
relational symbolic execution for fine
counter example - this kind of
generalized relational tribal where we
are saying basically that if we have our
precondition that says that our two
databases are adjacent adjacent when we
execute the same program on the on these
two databases we end up in a state where
basically the definition of differential
privacy holds now dealing with this kind
of with these kind of probabilistic
properties symbolically it's very
challenging for SMT solvers in nowadays
so one idea is to approach this problem
is to get rid of probabilities and
instead going back to standard
first-order logic and we can do that by
basically taking the only instruction
that generates in our language in our
abstract language generates randomness
and adding this new kind of axiom to our
system that says that every time we are
sampling in the true runs from Laplace
that might very well have different
means in the two runs we can create a
new relation between the samples that's
the one that we find in the post
condition by paying some of the budget
that we want to spend where the budget
is our epsilon variable so and this is
exactly what this axiom says if we
assume that
our database our edge agent and then we
have some bound between the differences
of the of the means in the of the
Laplace integer runs and we have until
now spent B of our maximum amount of
budget then we can do the sample and
assume that the samples are related by
that relation in the past condition but
we have to pay for that but now notice
that this K and K prime are symbolic
again and the idea of finding counter
example or finding proofs is going to
boil boil down to ask whether such K
exists or not and in case of multiple
Laplace assignment if there is at least
if there are enough if there are X
number of case that allowed this this
kind of a axiom to be applied enough
times so this turns boils down I mean
this brings us to a new way to prove or
disprove differential privacy which is
the following and doesn't have any
probabilities involved in particular now
what we want to prove is that starting
from two databases that are adjacent we
execute our program and we always end up
in a state that satisfies this post
condition which basically says that
every time the output variable of the
program see on the first run is equal to
some arbitrary value I then also in the
second run the output variable is equal
to I but the variable epsilon C that
denotes how much of my budget I spent so
far is less than or equal to Epsilon now
we can see this in an example an example
could be sparse factor which is a
standard standard algorithm that
basically takes an input a bunch of
queries
we assume there they're counting queries
Texan input a database and a maximum
number of iterations let's say of
positive vibrations and the idea of
sparse factor for those that are not
familiar with it is that we want to
answer top or bottom and we answer top
when the query when the eighth query on
the database is greater than the
threshold and we out bottom we output
bottom when that's not the case and we
want to do this privately and so that's
why we add first noise to the to the
threshold for some reason but we
importantly add noise to the query at
every iteration okay and and this has
been proved private absolutely
financially private and it's been proven
both I'm with pen and paper but also
formally but is that someone
implementing this algorithm might think
that releasing the noisy query could
still be private or maybe it doesn't
think of the of it but just introduces a
bug and we could use relational symbolic
execution to check that that's that's a
problem because for instance in this
case we could explore the path in red
and this would be the constraints that I
would gather from from that execution
and and then from the other execution
and from the relational part of the
execution we would get the constraints
in the second column in the third column
I mean I don't want you to digest all of
this but basically what's important is
that the constraint in the first two
columns basically the tardy constraint
scaler gathered from the first trace and
from the relational random assignments
basically do not imply the trace the
same trace the same trace on the on the
right
and in particular this can be answered
by an SMT solver which would provide a
model a counter example for this
implication now this doesn't mean that
the counter example provided would be
indeed a pair of databases that violate
the privacy condition because sometimes
symbolic execution in this case provides
also false positives
but this it's still an end to the fact
that the form of proof didn't go through
and so the user might go and check is
code for more information about it
another example is the following this is
still another buggy version of sparse
vector where we forget to noise the
query ok we know is the threshold but we
forget to know is the query and and now
we can do the same we execute in
parallel let's say this to symbolic
execution and now I pick my favorite
trace which is that one and this
corresponds basically to the output top
bottom because in the first case we are
below the threshold and in the other
case we are above threshold and this
generates this set of constraints right
where the queries are not noise and the
output is bottom on top and this is just
from the left execution now we also have
the the constraints that are obtained by
the relational by the proper relational
execution and again we notice that these
set of constraints do not imply the
right execution the mirrored right
execution in particular an SMT solver
will be able to give us a set of values
for key for these symbols here basically
Q 1 D 1 Q
- d 1 - 1 D 2 and Q 2 D 2 which are
namely the the answers to the queries
both on the left and on the right run
but in this case we did get a counter
example in the sense that once we
compute the probabilities of getting the
event bottom top on both rounds when I 1
when the inputs are such that the
equations on on the first row here
satisfied indeed we get a privacy loss
which is infinite this because if these
are the values of the of the input
basically there is some constant
probability of getting that event out on
the left run but there is ZERO
probability of achieving that event on
the right one so these are cases were
actually the senti solvers was was able
to give us a counter example and I think
I'm done yes and if there are questions
[Applause]
so a distinguishing feature of what
you're doing compared to that some of
the talks we heard earlier in the week
about verification is the generation of
counter examples yes the question really
is how useful are those counter examples
to debug the program if the program is
yeah I mean for personal opinion I mean
more than the bug in the code maybe I
can help you understand while why the
proof of privacy fails and because it
gives really you know two databases that
make the you know the privacy laws go
above into the Upsilon so of course
that's a matter of personally I find it
I would find it very useful to have some
you know to database this show why the
privacy laws feel very concrete
certificate really help you find where
in the code you need to I mean you made
a modification in the code is there in
some sense in which you get directed
towards that I mean that could be maybe
we could use like proof assistance like
tighten approaches based on type system
to see where actually the proof fails
once we feel once we you know execute
the programs with no specific input we
could see where the the proof fails and
that might give us an idea why the proof
fails that's one way I could look at it
does this symbolic execution allow
quantifying over unbounded size inputs
and the next is also the question would
like to explore Spector a number of
iterations so in theory if you make I
think the question maybe is that you
could make symbolic the M right
the problem with that is that then when
you execute the code basically you never
know when to terminate because you never
know when you reach the end so the
standard approach is to just put a fixed
constant bound and and see if within
those iterations you get a counter
example
yeah okay yes there is a way to get
around that would be to provide the
loops they loop within barians like you
say you provide a predicate that you
know it's true
after the loop and then that allows you
to skip the whole loop but you might
lose some information and and then the
account or example that you get might
not again be a real contour example
[Applause]